>> ♪ ♪
GREG IS YOUR LATEST FLING
PRETENDING HE IS LEFT WING.
JUST TO GET A QUICK POKE.
THE LATEST DATING TREND IS
CALLED WOKE FISHING PRETENDING
TO BE PROGRESSIVE TO LURE
PATTERSON.
-- PARTNERS.
THAT'S TERRIBLE.
DEATH EXPERT ALEX MILLER BROOK
TOLD THE DAILY MAIL THAT SINGLES
CAN PROTECT THEMSELVES BY ASKING
THEIR DATES TO ELABORATE ON
VIEWS OR WAITING TO SHARE YOUR
VIEWS.
YOU COULD MEET THEM AT A HIP
DOWNTOWN CAFE AND SEE IF THEY
SMASH THE WINDOWS.
TURN ON DON LEMON.
IF THEY DON'T RUN FROM THE ROOM
SCREAMING AND THROW UP YOU FOUND
SOMETHING WHO WILL THROW VEG AN
BURRITOS AT COPS WITH YOU.
MAILING IT IN TODAY, PEOPLE.
MICHELLE, THIS IS NOT NEW.
WOKE FISHING IS WHAT ALL GUYS
DID TO PRETEND THEY CARED ABOUT
[BLEEP] WHAT YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT.
GO TO AN ANIMAL RIGHTS CONCERT.
CLIMB CHANGE RALLIES IN THE '80s
AND 90s.
>> LET'S GO TO THE PLAZA AND
PROTEST APARTHEID BECAUSE THERE
ARE HOT CHICKS.
JUST SIT SOMEWHERE WITH A PUPPY.
THE WOMEN WILL FLOCK TO YOU.
>> Greg: THAT'S WORSE.
WHAT IF YOU ARE A HOMICIDAL
MANIAC.
>> TAKE THAT BACK.
I DID NOT GIVE THAT PUP.
>> Greg: I SHOULD GO TO
A POLITICAL RALLY WITH A PUPPY.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT.
AREN'T WE ALWAYS MANIPULATING
FOR A QUICK POKE.
NO ONE CARES.
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO
ASK YOU.
I AM AFRAID.
>> I AM A PROPONENT OF PEOPLE
MEETING IN PERSON AT A BAR.
THE OLD-FASHIONED WAY WITH
A BUNCH OF FRIENDS.
I DON'T REMEMBER US TALKING
ABOUT FEM ANYMORE WHEN HE FIRST
MET TO GET TO KNOW EACH OTHER.
THAT'S THE WAY THINGS HAPPEN
ONLINE.
THEN THE CONVERSATION GOES ON
AND ON BEFORE THEY MEET EACH
OTHER?
>> I RECOMMEND MEETING PEOPLE IN
PERSON.
>> Greg: KAT WHEN YOU WERE
DATING A GUY WOULD MEMORIZE
A POEM AND WOULD READ A POEM TO
YOU?
>> ONE GUY, NOW HE'S DEAD.
>> Greg: I DON'T THINK THAT WAS
A JOKE.
>> NO, OF COURSE NOT.
REST IN PEACE.
HE IS DEAD NOW.
I DIDN'T KILL HIM.
>> I AM GLAD YOU CLEARED THAT
UP.
>> Greg: I THINK YOURS IS A SLOW
DEATH.
>> IT'S LIKE I THINK THE KEY IS
JUST DON'T CARE IF THEY LIKE YOU
OR NOT.
>> Greg: THERE ARE 7 BILLION
PEOPLE.
>> IT'S NOT DIFFICULT TO FIND
A MAN WHO WANTS TO HAVE SEX WITH
YOU.
JUST BE YOURSELF.
>> Greg: THAT'S TRUE.
>> WELL, I CAN ONLY SPEAK FROM
THE GUY SIDE AND NOT EVERYONE
WANTS TO HAVE SEX WITH US.
I HAVE BEEN A LOT OF THINGS.
I HAVE BEEN AN ASTRONOMER.
A POET.
A MECHANIC.
WITH I WAS 18 IN A CLUB SOMEONE
ASKED ME IF I WAS FAT DILLION.
I SAID SURE.
I HAVE WORN MANY HATS TO GET
ASS.
THAT'S WHAT GUYS DO.
WE LIE.
THE ONLY THING WE ARE NOT GOOD
AT IS GETTING OUT THE LIE AND
END UP IN MARRIAGES WHERE WE
CARRY THE LIE AND KEEP GOING AND
GOING AND NEVER NOT KNOWING THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A MILKY WAY
IN THE SKY OR A BAR.
THAT'S WHAT GUYS DO.
THAT'S OUR PEACOCKING.
WE DON'T HAVE TRUE COLORS SO WE
HAVE TO [BLEEP] A LOT.
>> Greg: GO TO POLITICAL EVENTS
BECAUSE THE CONVERSATION IS
REGARD STARTED.
>> I WILL SAY THIS, GREG, IT
WILL BE LAST THING I SAY.
MOST THE TIME THEY DON'T -- YOU
DON'T HAVE TO SAY MUCH BECAUSE
THEY NEVER STOP TALKING.
ASTRONOMY.
>> ARE YOU SAYING THEY AS IN THE
WOMEN?
>> I CAN'T COMMIT TO THAT YES OR
NO. >> [LAUGHING].
>> YOU GUYS TALK A LOT AND FILL
IN THE BLANKS.
YOU ARE LIKE THE GAME WITH THE
BLANK LINES.
>> YOU WERE USING THE GENDER
NEUTRAL PRONOUN.
I RESPECT YOU FOR THAT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THEM CHICKS DON'T SHUT UP.
>> OH MY!
>> Greg: WE DON'T LIKE SEXISTS
AROUND HERE.
GET YOUR SEXIST BUTT OUT OF
HERE.
YEAH.
>> THAT WAS A GREAT SAVE.